Rachel's with us in California hey
Rachel welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi thank you for having me my gosh like
I'm so nervous but so excited to talk to
you how can we help
I was calling I had two questions the
first one is I'm going to financial
peace alone my husband doesn't want to
go with you because he says that I'm the
only one with money problems and I was
looking halogen just like get some
advice on how to talk to him better or
just actually get on this plan together
because we are not yeah
well going through Financial Peace
University when you're married without
your spouse is very dangerous because
you will come to think of your husband
as inept in the areas that you learn
about and decide that you want to work
on because he is inept in those areas
and that's not a good thing for me to
drive a wedge between you and your
husband so that bothers me I'm not
worried about that I'm also a little
worried about a husband who would say
something like that to his wife if I
said that to Sharon like you've got
problems I don't have problems that
wouldn't go well in the hillbilly
household I'll just tell you yeah I
don't think she'd be as sweet about it
as you were because you just kind of
wandered off the financial piece and
went well okay Sharon wouldn't have done
that it would have come out a little
differently at our house she's not a
jerk but she wouldn't react well to her
husband treating her that way so you
guys been married this will be our third
our fourth anniversary and we have to
babe used to oh yeah all right well your
husband does not know how to be married
that's our problem because when you get
married you join everything if you want
a high quality marriage and so it is
impossible for you to have money
problems in him not
and so sending you to be fixed as if
you're a car that needs to go to the
garage and have um be tuned up is not
very husbandly so if if he called me and
told me he did that I would call him a
jerk to his face and tell him he needs
to go learn how to go sit down with his
pastor with a good marriage counselor
and learn how to work with his wife now
how can you handle that
yeah I think we're gonna have to break
through his arrogance because if there's
financial problems in his house under
his roof and he thinks that they're all
someone else he's arrogant because he's
wrong and so I don't know how to do this
exactly because right now I'm just kind
of frustrated with him and when I think
about a second I turned 31 today and he
is 34 okay and you sure you got married
around the time he was thirty what's he
do for a living um he's a stay-at-home
dad at the moment
okay well that really adds to this
equation doesn't it yes he's starting
like side hustles with like selling food
and doing other other like little side
hustle things so it's just yeah what do
you look like how to I and you said earn
iron-60
I'm a teacher but I guess like after
taxes it would be fifty forty forty
eight to forty eight thousand to fifty
well I guess the way it would sound if
if we tried to do this a little more
gently a little sarcastic or caustic
than I was earlier it might sound like
this okay I talked to a financial coach
and he told me that almost zero percent
of couples that don't work together
succeed financially almost a hundred
percent of
10,000 millionaires that we researched
that were married worked together with
their spouse
very seldom it's almost never happened
statistically that two individuals that
are married operate as two separate
entities as if they're roommates instead
of being married and become successful
financially and build wealth so running
two different tracks inside the same
marriage inside the same household does
not lead to financial success you follow
me yeah and I think that's an important
data point that is a fact by the way and
so if we are going to be successful
financially we are going to have to work
together and even though you feel like
you know all of this material it would
be good for our marriage and our
relationship and increase our chances of
winning with money if we were aligned on
how we were going to go about it and
that would require you attend this class
with me and if it says no to that then
you need marriage counseling
you don't need Dave Ramsey okay okay
is there other stuff going on in your
marriage too yeah yeah like when you say
that what if they get married in the we
we kind of realize that like that really
hasn't happened yet
say that again like a we yeah hey you
know there's not a well y'all are still
operating as two separate entities and
that's what allows him to think that you
have a problem we need to know a problem
because he doesn't see you as one they
seizures two separate entities and
that's why I mean he's off off base on
this understanding of how marriage
relationships work they just don't work
that way and that's not to say that you
can't be all you can be as a
professional young woman and he can't be
all he can be as an independent
professional young man that's fine
that's not the point the point is is
when we're married we become one and so
that's what you guys have to work on so
I I would work on your marriage
more than I would work on your money and
I think you'll then lead back to going
through Financial Peace University
together but I'm afraid if you go over
there and learn a whole bunch of right
things and he doesn't agree with those
that it's gonna cause you to disrespect
him even more and I don't want that for
you I want you guys to get on the same
page okay okay thank you so much hey
thanks kiddo
you're gonna be all right but you do
seek some help with your marriage by the
way there's no shame in that people who
don't need help with their marriage
haven't been married very long Sharon I
about killed each other for a period of
time there it was rough our marriage
counselor war of referee's shirt and a
whistle I mean it was you know it was
bad and that was after bankruptcy but
anyway and during bankruptcy about
killed each other - she thought I was an
idiot cuz I was and I didn't like being
called an idiot especially when it was
right and so it didn't go well around
our house and we've got to learn how to
live together learn how to be married
and it's a it's a just raising kids I
don't come with a manual you gotta learn
how to be a parent you gotta read Meg
Meeker gonna be married you have to read
people like less parrot and Emerson egg
rich and you know love and respect is a
great one for you to read by the way I'd
be a great one for you to pick up and
read right now Rachel